[Music]
so okay so so how did your work on
discuss change the way that you looked
at things fundamentally I mean he gave
some indication of that already but what
else hasn't changed so since I was
coming out of a psychological literature
that was very focused on on sort of
secular secular ethics about justice and
fairness and then I began studying
discussed and looking at the broader
moral domain that almost all societies
have that then also led me to think
about well okay if disgust is a reaction
to things that seem to be degrading so
an interesting element of disgust is
this notion of degradation there are
always these vertical metaphors in which
disgust brings us down and and disgust
so a lot of some religious practice and
Judaism and Islam and and Hinduism is
about preparing your body to approach
God and purification and so that led me
to think well if there's an emotion
which is about seeing our lower base or
animal biological nature is there an
opposite emotion is there an emotion of
that we feel when we see some
manifestation or a higher nobler nature
and I was just beginning to think this
when I moved to UVA I got my first job
at the University of Virginia 1995 and I
read the set of Thomas Jefferson's
letters and in one letter he describes
he describes the feelings you get from
reading great fiction he advises a
cousin of his that he should buy fiction
for his library not just you know
serious works of law and philosophy and
he described he says doesn't he
describes the feeling of of having your
sentiments be elevated does it not
dilate your breasts or give you an open
feeling in your chest when you see these
acts of beauty and kindness and
gratitude I thought wow that's exactly
it and so because I've been studying
disgust I then started studying its
opposite which I and some others called
moral elevation so there's kind of
vertical metaphor of elevation and
degradation and it snaps on to the body
too with regards to my that's right high
low clean dirty yeah it's a beautiful
pairing and so having this language of
elevate
and discussed just really has helped me
see a lot of things I just I could just
see a lot of things happening it allows
me to like even you know manipulate like
if I'm applying for a grant proposal
like I can get very good at like having
an elevating ending and you know to to
you know end with a notable uplift and
so it just brought it's just broadened
by thinking about morality and this was
around 1995 and so again it just
prepared me so that and I'd already been
to India by that point I spent three
months doing research in erisa in
eastern India so it just brought in my
thinking and that's what allowed me
finally to understand conservatives
because I had always been on the left I
hated Ronald Reagan I thought
Republicans were stupid and evil and it
was only when I'd gone to India and
really tried to understand a traditional
religious hierarchical gender stratified
society tried to understand it in their
terms I didn't try to just bring in my
own my own Western left you know
left-leaning perspectives that I was and
this was all under the guidance of
richard shweder my postdoc supervisor at
the University of Chicago where did a
postdoc it was only then that I was able
to sort of get inside their minds and
their moral system and see that there
were alternative moral worlds they each
had their own logic and that was the
metaphor I came to it you know the time
you know the Matrix movies were very
popular so the metaphor the matrix as a
consensual hallucination made a lot of
sense it's writing up with the idea of
just speaking with moral matrices
whichever different moral matrices that
are grounded in biology their biology in
the sense that gives us the potential
it's like the building blocks of this
matrix can't be just anything that comes
it comes from our experiences our
embodied experiences and again George
Lakoff is the master of that thinking
and so it was only then that that I was
able to now listen to conservative talk
radio and Christian religious radio and
see rather than just like oh those
stupid terrible people say like oh wow
yeah you know I can see that they're
striving for a certain version right
right so you started to understand their
metaphorical language essentially that's
right and that was like kind of like my
you know I know Great Awakening or
scales falling from my eyes but you know
since but it took a few more you took a
number a lot more years but eventually I
kind of
like hold out the implants from my eyes
and I stop seeing everything so through
a partisan lens and I'm not on any side
now and just trying to understand what
the hell is well it's really useful it's
really useful to understand that there
are actual reasons why people see the
world differently and that you can't
just easily say that one is right and
the other is wrong because the Liberals
are correct when it comes to borders
that if you thicken them too much and
diminish the information flow you risk
making the society so static that any
radical environmental transformation
will sink it it's the case but the
Conservatives are right in that you pay
a big price with regards to newcomers
and new information with regards to risk
to exposure to contaminating Welty
contamination period but also to
contaminating ideas and so then I've
always thought you know the the
environment itself moves back and forth
like a snake in some sense and what
we're trying to do is stay on the center
of its back and the only way we can do
that is by people by having people pull
to the right and say be careful and
people pull to the left and say well
yeah but be open with that dialogue and
the exchange of information that that
dialogue allows we can maybe specify the
center of that moving target and stay
and stay well and stay on the back let's
yeah okay so that's a really complicated
metaphor with the snake but I think it's
a perfect way in to what's going on on
campus and to why viewpoint diversity is
so important